so as usual the media brings nothing to
the table except the chip on their
shoulder and a hunger for chaos and last
night they saw the fog of war as the
perfect time for solemn pronouncements
courtesy of Iran television this bit I
am I'm not sure about that Iran state
media is claiming that 30 US soldiers
have been killed in this attack and out
this is not confirmed this is just
coming from Iranian media but we have
just stepped over the precipice ah the
precipice now how did that guy get that
info so fast you can't even get a box
for that quickly
maybe that should have tipped him off
meanwhile NBC invited its viewers to
watch live coverage of Salah Monty's
burial
I hear Michael Moore lowered his belly
at half-mast and over Morning Joe all
hair and no brains ties it all back to
Russia it would be hard to believe that
Donald Trump would launch attacks into
Iran without speaking first of Vladimir
Putin this would obviously lie at the
heart of Vladimir Putin's interest since
Iran has long been seen by Putin as a
client state of Russia my god
thanks Beavis but what about Butthead I
bet he thinks this president is
impulsive this is a president who is
impulsive and doesn't think through the
implications of his actions this could
have been a massive catastrophe
proportions that we just can't fully
appreciate and so this was this was a
dangerous night at the casino for
president Trump nothing changes he's
like a stopped clock with Brylcreem so
imagine going to the movies and facing
the wrong way in your seat
that's the media always missing the big
picture preferring a story that matches
the voices in their heads saying hey
guys seems a little early to call this
World War 3 that only pisses off that
Jeff Zucker's of the world who count on
chaos to make Bank just ask the
Covington kid yet even after that lesson
they still can't stop we're only here at
this moment this very dangerous moment
because of Donald Trump's impulses these
kinds of world-changing and historic
calamities they're at the early stages
of a hot war it
is a monumental moment this is exactly
what many foreign policy and national
security analysts feared here in
Washington this could have a very
significant effect we may be on a road
to a very different Middle East
come come sunrise this is a really very
grave and serious moment yep
look I ain't saying this isn't serious
but all the sweaty hysterics come off as
wishful thinking
can you just dial it back a little
especially when you're always wrong but
maybe that reporter was right we are on
the precipice of peace not war it's
certainly not over it's Wednesday
which is better than Tuesday last night
was just another chance to scare the
crap out of us for the media in the
Trump era the apocalypse is every day
that ends in Y Shannon why I notice that
the media rather than analyzing their
mistakes immediately repeats it by going
what happens next
they don't say like wow we really
screwed up they go well what's gonna
happen tomorrow I'm noticing that now
it's like okay we thought there was
World War three no war but it could
happen tomorrow well he could yes I mean
these guys say that it's not over the
ayatollah says it's not over but you're
right I think that even as I said
earlier when they get what they want
from the president or what they think
they want which they said there should
not be a response we want to see him
measured not do anything crazy he comes
out and gives this speech which was very
calm almost monotone saying we want
peace we want to help the people of Iraq
all kinds of things The Washington Post
this pops up in my email an op-ed piece
that says they called it a deranged
speech that's a quote yes they say there
was no eloquence it was filled with lies
garbled a terrible sweeps that image
that didn't convince anyone
he's never get it and win over some of
these people so not gonna happen
you know why I was watching CNN at the
gym cuz that's what's on you know I
watched I saw Barbara Starr ah
I saw Gloria Borger er I saw Christian
Amanpour it seems on the dreadmill Iran
toe no but it seems to me it's the same
old names in the same old faces saying
the same same old stuff it's because
you're gonna be some quality control you
mean all the way back to weapons of mass
destruction immediately the media just
went along say oh yeah
we'll go along with the administration
yeah sure there must be weapons but the
wrong note that the presses job is to be
skeptical and to challenge with our
legislature aware of the facts where are
the facts that justify you going out and
setting off what could have been a
tragic situation we're happy today that
things have gone down quietly but you
know one got to understand one errant
missile could have been a tragedy the
other thing to say I really disagree
with the business about the reporter I
think reporters who are in a country
like Iran where there's no First
Amendment no protections you know I
think of reporters learning Iran state
TV well but if that's if you say this is
what the government says we can't
confirm it if you're in North Korea 30
Americans are dead you know a little
irresponsible no it's not if that's what
he has he attributed directly a TV he
attributed directly to the Iranian
government well I'm just saying that's
reported as a guy who's been in the
field for 40 years I appreciate that I
know I know
but imagine if you were in North Korea
sometimes so you know even a box
reporter has to say something's because
the North Koreans are monitoring how
about this the Iranians are saying
thirty are dead the Americans are saying
none right the American public can make
a decision instead saying they're saying
30 a dead I don't know one of the
Cooper's actually I don't know if that's
true or not
what are you okay maybe you should well
now we know what well now we know but
then we didn't let range breaking news
Christopher hey said clearly the war in
Iran is madness and strategically and
morally a disaster in the making and
don't believe anyone that tells us
otherwise oh thanks I appreciate Donald
Trump wag the dog and now the dog is
wagging Trump really by hitting the
middle of an empty base yeah it's like
okay so he prevents Benghazi happening
at the US Embassy in Baghdad the whole
press says it could have been at
Benghazi it was in the Ghazi and then
they find out more information and it's
actually not that and then he doesn't
get credit for preventing an attack and
then they continue on and criticize him
when he takes decisive action to protect
Americans can't went on that but one
they teach you in journalism school not
to repeat a report government propaganda
and they teach you all about how most of
the media in these countries is run by
the government and you shouldn't this
you shouldn't glorify or publicize
anything they say as fact and for them
to
oddly say I am confirmed I don't know
but then state it as as something that
should be taken seriously really
undermines they're kind of like the
second shooter at mass shoot is just you
know there's another shooter out there
and it never is there's only one it's
like they dig they can't wait I think
right the credibility the person whose
credibility is undermined here is Iran's
not ours because it's don't but you got
a report that when you're in a breaking
news situation you're just trying to you
know control what you get and he
attributed it properly it was the rain
gives us a quick chance to thank our
reporters Trey Yanks Jennifer Dylan
Lucas Thomas and how do you know when
this story begins to turn the
president's direction when they talk
about impeachment they'll pivot as soon
as they realize there's no there there I
was on location throughout this whole
thing at Equinox Jim on the ground